[MUSIC PLAYING]
KIRAN DAVULURI: We've got a
great session for you today.
So we're going to
cover specifically
around how retailers
have prepared and planned
for a great big season, in
this case, Black Friday,
on Google Cloud Platform.
So we've got a lineup of two
great speakers and me here.
So my name is Kiran Davuluri.
I'm a customer engineer
with Google Cloud.
I focus on retail
customers, specifically.
We've also got Jimit Ladha,
who's a VP of engineering
at Kohl's.
And we've got
Andre Fatala, who's
the CTO of Magalu, a
well-known Brazilian retailer.
So this is what we're
going to cover today.
I'm going to walk you
through the importance
of the peak session,
specifically
how a lot of retailers handle
Black Friday, Cyber Monday,
peak season.
And then I'm also going to
cover what Google Cloud can
do specifically to
help you navigate
through the peak season and
make sure that you plan,
prepare, and execute
for a flawless peak.
And then I'm going
to hand it over
to Jimit from
Kohl's, who's going
to cover the story of Kohl's and
their journey to Google Cloud.
And then I'm going to bring
in Andre Fatala, who's
the CTO of Magalu.
And he's going to cover
their digital transformation
journey and the amazing things
they're doing on Google Cloud.
And lastly, we'll wrap up
with some of the resources
that you all can use to be
successful on Google Cloud.
So just setting the stage,
I know that a lot of you
are retailers.
And the retail
industry as a whole
is going through a pretty
big transformation right now.
And a lot of retailers have
seen sales slowing down
in multiple channels.
But e-commerce continues to be
one of the key areas of growth
that most retailers are seeing.
For example, we know that
the e-commerce, sales have
grown to more than $2 trillion.
We know that year growth for
the sales is more than 24%.
And this is the reason why
retailers are investing
on the e-commerce platform.
However, when
people are investing
in their e-commerce
platform, there
is a lot of expectations
from customers
on how an e-commerce
platform should look like.
The standards are very high.
Customers are now used
to a very high level
of fast, personalized service.
We have studies that have shown
that if your website takes
more than three seconds to
load, 40% of the shoppers
will abandon your website.
And even if people have put
their items in the cart,
if the website crashes, a
quarter of your shoppers
are going to abandon
their shopping cart.
So what this means is
customer experience
is critical for retailers
on their e-commerce sites
to differentiate themselves.
And without a fast,
personalized, consistent
experience, it's
hard for customers
to continue shopping
on your website.
Now, this becomes
even more difficult
when you have a peak
season like Black Friday.
Now retailers have
understood that they
need to focus on e-commerce.
They've invested a lot of money
on the infrastructure required
to support their
e-commerce websites.
However, it's still been
very difficult to accommodate
traffic spikes, for example.
If you just look at the
Black Friday that happened,
retailers have had a risk
of about $300 million
of lost sales due to
application crashes.
And for an average
Fortune 1000 company,
we know that infrastructure
downtime on average
can cost $100,000
an hour on average.
So what this means
is retailers have
a lot of money riding on this.
And this is not just losses
in terms of revenue and sales.
It also talks to
the fact that you
can get, in some
cases, negative press
if your website does not perform
as intended on a peak season
when there's a lot of
eyeballs on your website.
But let's just take a
step back and understand.
I mean, we know that retailers
are investing in e-commerce.
We have a lot of--
companies spend
$62 billion a year.
But why is it so difficult
to handle a large scale
event like Black Friday?
It's not like Black
Friday creeps up on you.
I mean, it's easy
to predict when
Black Friday is going to occur.
So let's take a sample example
of how a transaction looks
like on a website traffic.
The reason why it's so
difficult to handle the spikes
here is you have a
baseline traffic that
continues to be stable.
And very, very quickly,
it can scale to five times
your usual traffic or more.
So your infrastructure
and your processes
have to handle this
quick increase in load
and continue to serve the great
experience that it did even
when the load was
one fifth of what
it was just a few hours prior.
And that is a challenge.
So one thing that most
retailers have seen
is, hey, the Cloud can help you.
Google Cloud is very
well-suited for handling
these sort of things.
We have a great network.
We have a secure,
scalable infrastructure.
But that's not what I'm going to
focus on today because you have
tons of great
sessions that you can
go to and understand
how the infrastructure
itself can help you scale.
But what I want to touch upon
is what else can Google Cloud
do to make sure
that you have a very
good experience and a flawless
peak season on Google Cloud?
If you just understand the--
let's assume that
you guys are running
on an on-premise hardware.
Everything is
within your control.
The teams that run the
support, the teams that
are on your network, the teams
that run your infrastructure
are all within your control.
But when you move to
the Cloud, you're now--
there is a sense that you
are now ceding control
to other companies
that might not
be as invested in your success.
And that can cause
some concerns.
And we understand that.
So what we are trying
to do is figure out
if we can be a trusted
partner with you guys
and help alleviate some of
those anxiety and concerns
when you move to the Cloud.
So what we have
done while working
with some of our retailers
is develop the program
that we call Peak Preparedness
Program with one simple goal.
Our goal is to deliver
a flawless peak season
for our retail customers.
And I'll walk you through
how exactly we do that.
As you know, for a
great event, there
are three distinct stages.
We have a planning stage wherein
you define your objectives.
You look at your architecture
and know exactly what capacity
you would need to
execute on that.
You then have a
testing and adjusting
period where you run load
test and performance test.
And lastly, during
the event, you
will monitor and tune
the system to make sure
that it continues to meet
the service-level objectives
that you have set
up for the system.
Let's take a sample Black
Friday, Cyber Monday, timeline.
And I'll walk you
through how exactly
we help our customers here.
We start engaging during--
pretty early, right?
We start engaging towards
the August, mid of August,
end of August time
frame in order
to finalize the capacity plans.
By this time, most
retailers have
an idea of how the traffic
is supposed to look like.
We continue to work with them.
And usually, we've
seen that customers
have a code freeze around
the end of September,
October frame.
And then they go ahead
and during this time
do a lot of load and
performance testing.
And this is critical
because it tells them
how stable the environment
is and how effective
the environment is in
handling unpredictability.
And we continue to work with
retailers alongside them.
In addition to that, one of
the key things that we offer
is the tabletop exercises.
Now, what we've seen
whenever a disruption occurs
is it's not just a technical
issue that happens.
A lot of times, communication
structures breakdown.
And what we do with
the tabletop exercise
is kind of simulate a
disaster in progress.
Take an example of
a retailer is down.
Twitter is blowing up.
And every hand is on deck.
But then someone is not
available for an escalation
path.
So what we do is we
work with customers
and make sure that we have a
primary mode of communication
that's set up.
And in addition to the
primary mode of communication,
we also work with
fallback options
in order to make sure that
even if something goes wrong,
you always have a backup plan.
And the tabletop
exercises have been
extremely critical
for our customers
to be successful on peak.
Once the tabletop
exercises are done,
we have a customer
infrastructure phase.
The other area where Google is--
where we differentiate ourself--
is the fact that we work with
our product engineering team
to enforce a code freeze
around the peak weekend.
So if you take the weekend of
Black Friday and Cyber Monday
and before that as
well, what we do
is we work with our
product engineering
to make sure that Google does
not push any new features
or enhancements.
The idea is we understand the
effort and investment that you
are putting on Google Cloud.
And we want to make sure that
you guys have a great peak
season.
And this is something that
is very unique to what we do.
Once the code
freeze is done, you
don't have to worry about
Google pushing something
and then that causing
any disruption.
After that, during
the scale down,
we continue to support
you all the way
till the end of December when
the shopping season starts
winding down.
Now, if you've
noticed one thing,
I've completely skipped
over Black Friday,
the actual weekend
when things happen.
So for Black Friday, what
we do is we make sure
that you have access
to all the resources
you need in order
to be successful.
So for example, you have
an onsite account team.
So for certain
customers, you can
have your account team
be onsite supporting you
so that you know who to reach.
You have one single
channel of contact
that you can start helping
to track all your issues.
We also have a
fully-staffed support team.
We don't want our retailers
to be in a position
where they're
waiting on a resource
to look at an issue
that's happening.
So we fully staff
our support team
and make sure that
everyone's aware,
not just of their
technical knowledge,
but also about the customers
they are supporting
and what the potential
impacts could be.
So in addition to
all of this, we also
have a central
BFCM War Room that
is staffed by Googler's
from various organizations.
This includes our professional
services organization.
This includes our site
reliability engineers.
This includes our engineering.
And you also have channels
into our executive sponsors.
So what this means is
when an issue happens,
we are able to very quickly
bring the respective people
into a single room
and try and make sure
that we can address any
disruption that's happening.
So as you all know,
success is a team effort.
And we understand
that customers,
when moving from a traditional
on-premise kind of system,
they have these concerns
about, hey, how do I manage
all these teams that are there?
How do I manage my own teams?
How do I manage all the teams
that are internal to Google
and make sure that
we all work together?
And that's the problem
the Peak Preparedness
Program is designed to address.
What we do is we bring
all the specialists,
all highly-experienced
Googlers from different teams,
like, for example, our
Professional Services,
the account teams that work
day in and day out with you,
our support teams, again,
highly-experienced, supporting
personnel, our Customer
Reliability Engineering
teams, and representatives from
our product and engineering
teams as well.
And all of this
with the single goal
of making sure that you guys
have a flawless peak season.
So we've talked about how
Google Cloud has a program
to help customers
navigate through this
and make sure that they are
successful during Black Friday.
What I'd like to do now
is bring our customers
to talk about their stories.
We've got two great
customers here today.
We've got Kohl's, who you
all know as a very famous US
retailer.
We also have Magalu, who is
a famous Brazilian retailer.
We have got the CTO
from there to talk
to us about their
transformation journey.
So I'll first invite Jimit, the
VP of Engineering from Kohl's.
He leads the DevOps
and the data science
division for Kohl's e-commerce
and big data platform.
And he's been a
great partner to us.
When Kohl's decided to partner
with Google Cloud in 2017,
his team was one
of the first teams
to bring their solutions
onto Google Cloud.
I'll hand it over
to him to walk us
through how they prepared for
it and how they plan for peak.
Take it over, Jim.
JIMIT LADHA: Thank you.
KIRAN DAVULURI: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JIMIT LADHA: So as
Kiran mentioned,
Black Friday, for
us, being a retailer,
it's a very important thing.
Kohl's, as most of
you all know, is
a leading omnichannel retailer.
We run more than 1,100
stores in the US.
We have stores in 49 states.
And we provide a lot of--
we provide a lot of our
own brands, which we run,
and a lot of other
national brands, Nike,
Levi's, a lot of them.
And overall, we make
sure that the customers
are the primal, most
important people for when
they come to shop.
So all our channels
are in-store.
Our omnichannel, digital,
desktop, mobile, tablet,
in-store experiences,
the customers
need to get the fast response,
the expected response
that you are always ready for.
And that is one thing
that we really focus on.
And then we are committed to it.
We also do a lot of--
give back to the community.
Over the years, we have
done almost $700 million
of giveback.
So we really look at
the primary thing of--
make the customer
prime, most important.
And our purpose is to
inspire and really empower
the families for them
to live fulfilled lives.
So I'll walk you
through a quick journey.
We have been in the e-commerce
business for quite some time.
But we realized back in
2016 that we need to get out
of the data center business.
How do we get out
of the traditional
running our own data centers,
running everything on prem?
How do we manage all the
network, storage, availability,
everything else?
So we started early.
We spent a lot of
time thinking about,
how do we break
up our e-commerce?
How do we derisk ourselves so
that we can actually understand
what the cloud looks like?
We can take the
risk and move on.
So one of the things
we started was we
moved our search platform, which
was a traditional technology
running on Oracle
technologies, to open-source
solar technology.
Moved it to the cloud, got
some experience from it.
Learned on how to manage
cloud workloads, what
needs to be done.
Very soon after, in 2017, we
pulled our search and browse
experience, which
is all our products,
how the search works, how--
your product detail page,
your product matrix page
and everything else looks like.
We moved all of those
also to the cloud.
And that is where we spent
a lot of time understanding,
how do we do things
like service discovery?
How do we do things
like secrets management?
What does scalability
really mean to us?
How do we identify which
regions, which zones do we
want to run our workloads in?
So it really helped
us understand
how complex the
cloud can be and what
are the different
things that we can
do to make sure that our
solution is always available.
Actually, when we
started in 2016,
we thought we will
go to GKE, but then
very soon realized that we,
Kohl's, as an enterprise,
was not ready for GKE.
That's when we had
to switch back.
We moved to GCE and put all our
workloads onto the Google Cloud
Engine just to make sure we had
much more control over it, how
do we do things,
and we managed it.
Soon after that, in 2018, we
brought our cart and check out,
our account management,
which is the real core
of an e-commerce
business, brought it over
to the Google Cloud.
This is where we had to really
focus on high availability.
We had to focus on consistency
that the user experience--
user could be on
any server anywhere.
And they change a
password, that should still
be seamless for them.
They can add payment.
It should be seamless to them.
So we spent a lot of time making
sure our services are highly
available, very scalable.
And we spent a good amount of
time learning Canary releases,
blue-green releases, and all
the other things that are a must
when you really move
to a cloud solution.
Within that, we also realized
a lot of different things.
Like we say, yes,
Google is awesome.
But then sometimes our
needs are very different.
And typical example would
be we went to Google ILBs
but very soon realized that our
workloads were not well managed
through the ILBs.
We could see some
servers get a lot
of more requests than the other
because the ILBs typically work
on a total size of the packet.
What's this for us?
Our user sessions
are so different.
The traffic looked
very different.
So we had to figure out how to
put a proxy in front of them
just to make sure that our
traffic is well balanced
and it works seamlessly
the way it needs to.
This is where we
really realized what
and how do we build
for the cloud?
Because cloud, overall, is
a really awesome technology.
But it brings a lot
more complexities to us.
Think of a networking team.
All of us, if we
are running on-prem,
we are running our
own data centers,
we have one or two or three
networking guys to go to.
Something went wrong,
call this person.
That person knows how
a load balancer work.
That person knows
how a firewall works.
That person knows what to do
when something bad happens.
Guess what?
On the cloud, that is
not really the same.
You open a ticket
for an SRA team.
That team knows VMs.
That team knows the ILBs.
That team knows security.
So this is where we had
to partner with Google.
We had to understand all
these nuances to make sure
that we are built
and we understand
how degraded mode works, how we
can quickly failover and react
whenever something happens.
Because Google, being
the great company
it is, they provide
us five nines--
99.999% availability.
Guess what?
A one-second impact
to their network
could become a 10-second
impact to my platform.
So we really needed--
we had to understand
how to manage those
and how to make
ourselves resilient
because some of things
are going to happen.
And we need to be ready to
understand how to react to it.
Same things with a
computer platform.
They manage their own VMs.
There is a lot of
good CPUs, cores,
everything else is
available behind the scene.
But then things go wrong.
How do we identify
and how do we deep
dive when your server
suddenly is strapping for CPU?
It's not able to scale.
We had to spend time.
We had to learn with Google--
learn how to build the resilient
architecture that we needed,
how to build the KPIs, how to
build all the basic monitoring
and awareness of reacting
fast to a problem
whenever it happens.
The other thing we
learned was stock-outs.
Again, now the technologies
are getting better.
But when we started,
it was very interesting
where if one of the zone
had a stock out, how do
you react to it?
Do you stop building
your cluster,
or you go back
and figure out how
to add individual
zones to a cluster
and build servers
on just one zone?
So these are realities
of the cloud,
which, unfortunately,
you only realize
after you start diving
into it and after you
start working through it.
But again, as I said, the
technologies are awesome.
We do need to
change our thinking.
And we need to change how we
deal with it because there
is a lot of things that we need
to be aware of to get it done.
And Google, being the
great partner they are,
they really helped us
through a lot of it.
When come back to
Black Friday, how
do we ensure that our
e-commerce platform
is available, is ready for our
customers to transact with?
As I mentioned
earlier, customers
are the most important
users of our system.
And we need to make sure
that they get the best
experience, the
best performance,
and a seamless check out,
seamless log in experience.
So we really look at
performance from the get-go.
For us, performance is
not an afterthought.
It is something which is
really built into our DNA.
Whenever there is a new
initiative, that starts.
application that we build,
whenever we look at anything
that our customer interacts
with, we put a lot of
focus on performance.
We make sure that it goes
through the lifecycle
of defining the NFRs,
understanding what the business
goals are, understanding
what the availability
requirements are.
Go through the level of
testing that is required,
different-- you want
to test features.
You want to test scalability.
You want to test the whole
ecosystem in an integrated
view.
You also want to test
and certify production.
You expected everything to work.
You went through your SDLC.
You did dev, QA, stress
and everything else.
But how do we ensure that things
don't go wrong in production?
You want to really push it.
That's where we have
to think through
how do we run stress
test, performance test,
on an existing
production environment?
So we had to go
through all of this
and work through,
making sure that we
are able to give a very
seamless available platform
to the customers.
Peak, again, this is
where Kiran walked us
through Google timeline.
For us, as I mentioned,
peak is every day.
We don't think about peak.
And we don't wake up in
August, September, October
to say, OK, how
should it look like?
Monthly, we do releases.
We do a ton of changes in our
ecosystem in an environment.
And we ensure every
solution that goes out
there is fully certified.
It's fully validated.
It is highly performant.
It meets the business
needs that are there.
It can scale-up, scale-down, do
all the things that are needed,
that is highly--
it is properly certified for
the use case that are there.
Sometime, June, July time frame
is when we kind of start diving
into, OK, business.
It's time for you to give
us your requirements,
give us what your
projections look like.
Tell us what you need.
I think most of you guys, if you
are from the technology area,
business thinks differently.
They think about
peak as dollar value.
They understand they want
to sell x million dollars
worth of goods.
That doesn't really
convert into technology.
We spend the time taking
their requirements,
converting them
to our technology,
and converting them to a
measurable unit, transactions
per second, queries per second,
and everything else that we
need.
We really do a deep
dive to make sure
that we have built it and scaled
our solution to the point where
it meets the business
needs, after which we
start running our tests.
We figure out how the
traffic projection
needs to look like, which
component is going to get what,
how scalable things are.
How does failure work?
How does degraded
mode work, et cetera.
So we do spend a lot
of time in making sure
that we have done DHA, we
have done the DR testing,
we have done certification, and
we have certified the solution
to be completely ready.
We also spend a lot
of time in actually
trying to make sure that we
are aware of our dependencies.
Being a retailer,
all of us understand
we have to depend on
our payment systems.
We have to depend on
our fraud systems.
We have to depend on all
the third-party integrations
that we work with.
How do we derisk ourselves?
How do we make sure
that we understand
when one of those systems
goes bad, what do we do?
So we spend a lot of time on it.
We build very clear
monitoring strategies.
rollout strategies
as well as, how do we react?
When something
happens, if it's bad,
how do we not think
about what to do?
It should be just a
one, two, three process.
So coming into
September, October,
we actually run as if
we have Black Friday.
We run all the tests.
We certify, we make
sure we have tested
individual zones, all the
zones within a region,
across multiple regions.
How does things work?
If things go wrong,
how do we react?
Databases have a problem,
caching system has a problem,
any subcomponent has a
failure, what do you do?
If your inventory system fails,
do you stop taking the order?
Or do you figure out how to
put that order in a backlog
so that you can reprocess it?
So there is a lot
of things that need
to be thought through
and implemented.
And we spend a lot
of time making sure
that it's all done
by end of September
because the most
interesting thing is
September is the last functional
release that we allow.
October and November are purely
performance only, make sure
that everything works
the way it needs to
and it is ready for a
Black Friday, Cyber Monday.
We work very closely with
Google, as Kiran earlier said.
Their PSO teams, their
SRE teams, CRE teams,
they came and showed
us how should we
think about the SLIs, the SLOs.
How should we plan so that
we let the Google engineer,
during a time of
crisis, be aware
that this is the dashboard
they need to look at?
Google's view of our
system is only Stackdriver.
They don't understand
our functionality.
They don't understand how
we have built the systems.
So we had to ensure
that we have given them
the right KPIs, the right
dashboards, the right awareness
that when I call
somebody at Google
and tell them I need help, they
can jump directly to the area
where they need to look
at and help us back.
So the CRE and the
SRE teams really
helped us get there
so that we were
ready for the Black Friday,
Cyber Monday days when
Kiran spoke about.
We also had the teams
available in the office,
on hangout chats,
everywhere else so
that if something does
happen, what do we do?
And as Kiran said, it was all
planned, collaborated, tested.
We understood what
needs to be done
and how it needs to be done.
The products that we
use, as I mentioned,
we run most of the
Google Cloud Engine.
We run their Compute.
We run their networks.
We run the Bigtable, Cloud
Spanner, Big Dataproc,
all the technologies
that we have,
we are using purely
for e-commerce areas.
Stackdriver, that's a
pretty awesome tool.
Does a lot of insights,
allows us to monitor,
allows us to react, allows us
to get the KPIs that we need
to be able to help understand
where things are going
and how things are working out.
What's next?
I think the things that we are
focusing on this year is cost.
I did skip through it.
But cost is a very
important problem.
Cloud makes it very easy
to say, yes, it's Cloud.
Everything is available.
Flip a switch and you
have your servers.
Guess what?
If you leave the switch on,
you keep on paying for it.
We need to realize
how to manage this.
In our old data
center ways, we never
really cared about licensing.
It was enterprise licenses.
Stand up as many
servers as you want.
Guess what?
When you come to the
Cloud, that might change.
So you need to have a primary
area and a primary focus on it.
So we're going to spend more
time on cost management.
We are also going to look
at the newer technologies
that Google has, purely GKE,
look at their Dataproc versus
BigQuery, look at areas
that we can now learn
and grow to a newer one.
We want to spend
more time on AIOps.
That is something which
I'm assuming all of us
really want to get
to is, how do I
not get into managing
1,000 servers
where somebody has
to know what to do?
How do I have a
robot, a bot running
behind the scene
which can react and do
the things that are needed?
How do I scale my
system down every night?
How do I scale it
up in the morning?
So those are the areas
we are focusing on.
And then scale our
API platform, A we
need to ensure that the
API platform, which we use,
which is also Google Apigee,
is highly available and ready
for us for peak.
Let me get Kiran
back on the screen.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
KIRAN DAVULURI: Thank you.
JIMIT LADHA: Thank you.
KIRAN DAVULURI:
Thank you, Jimit.
I think that was a
great story of how
you partnered with Google.
We learned a lot.
We learned a lot together.
And you're on Google Cloud.
And thank you for being
a great partner to us.
I'd now like to introduce Andre
Fatala, the CTO of Magazine
Luiza.
Fatala, as he is known,
is responsible for leading
the technology and the
digital transformation effort
alongside the CEO, Fred Trajano.
And he has been the
primary architect
for the digital transformation.
Magazine Luiza has
transformed from
a brick-and-mortar retailer,
who had an e-commerce presence,
into an industry-leading
digital platform.
And Magazine Luiza, or
Magalu, as it's known,
is seeing a double-digit
growth today
compared to the other
Brazilian retailers.
In addition to
that, it's not only
seeing a double-digit
growth, it's
also holding its own against all
of the other digital commerce
giants that are trying to
enter the Brazilian market.
So I'll hand it over to him.
And then he'll talk to us
about all the transformation
that they've done.
You have the mic?
Here, you can have this.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDRE FATALA: So
hello, everyone.
In Magalu, our approach is
a business approach for us
and driven by technology.
So over the past
five years, we have
done a complete transformation,
the company and all the things
about omnichannel, like pickup
in store, last mile delivery,
mobile apps, our
sales associates,
and our own
marketplace platform.
And we were able
to do this quickly
because we used a hybrid
approach based on APIs
and microservice in the company.
So we have a great results too.
One thing to point out is we
did them both, in the stores,
in our e-commerce
platform together.
And we have our GMV of
digital around 40% right now.
And in the last three years,
the stock price of the company
grew 106 times.
It's pretty much
the way that we see
the transformation of
the company from 2015
to what we have now.
So talking about
the Cloud, that's
our journey to the Cloud.
Actually, we start in 2011
when we found R&D team
to start playing around with new
technologies in a different way
of development inside
Magazine Luiza.
And we understand
that the Cloud is not
about only to reduce
costs and scalability.
The idea is it's--
although it's a benefit
too, but the reason
is that we need to empower
developers the way that we see.
And we need to be able
to create fast and drive
our business really fast.
So last year, we decide to
do not just a hybrid but also
on multicloud strategy.
And we already using Apigee
and Kubernetes for some time.
But last year, we decide to move
all the data workloads to GCP.
And we were very happy with
the applications on GCP.
And it's been great so far.
And then we decide to move our
e-commerce platform as well.
So one of the really critical
piece of this strategy
has been the Apigee
API management.
It's not just infrastructure.
It's a critical strategy to give
the speed, agility, and control
so we can serve our
customers and manage
business while at the same time
make life easier to development
teams.
And that's a pretty much
the growth of API calls
that we have on our platform
since 2017, beginning of 2017.
Then after playing around
the data workloads on GCP,
we decide to do
something really crazy.
We decide to migrate our
e-commerce platform apps to GCP
just 60 days before
Black Friday.
And why here we
decide to do this
is because we really
believe that it
would have the best Black Friday
performance running on GCP.
And we worked really tight with
a Google team, the PSO team.
We have teams onsite
on Black Friday,
help us to support all the
operation on the Black Friday.
And we migrate 113
apps in just 53 days.
Yeah.
And it's a lot of hard
work from the teams.
But it's paid off.
It was our biggest and
easiest Black Friday
ever in the history
of the company.
The sales grew around 65%.
We have a peak of close
to 2,000 orders per minute
and all of huge numbers.
So how that possible for
us to move so quickly?
It's because we are
really believers
of the Kubernetes since 2016.
And it's enables to
move really quickly
to hybrid and
multicloud strategy.
We built, in 2016, a platform
as a service call Teresa.
It's open-source if someone
is interested to help
us or collaborate to
continue to evolve our PaaS.
And because of Teresa, we
we're able to just create
the clusters, the
Kubernetes clusters on GCP
and start moving our
workloads really fast.
So that's a little
bit of numbers
off our stack on
GCP and the numbers
that we had in the
peaks of Black Friday.
So we reached almost
8,000 pods on the peak
and more than 44 petabytes
of logging in that month.
So it's a pretty much really
good numbers of this stack.
About products
we're using today,
it's a lot of GCP service.
And we are using all
GCP service today
because I don't want my teams
thinking about infrastructure.
We want to focus on
delivering value to customers
and build software to
drive our strategy forward.
And GCP has been a
great partner on these.
And we can use what we need and
the time that we think that is
the best time to this strategy.
So what's next for Magalu?
We are going to finish
the migration now
of our brick-and-mortar apps.
We have around 600 apps
to move in 90 days.
And probably, we are going
to finish the migrate
by the end of May.
And then we are planning to open
our APIs that we are calling
our platform-- as a
Magalu as a Service
and let the partners that
we have on our marketplace
to use our fulfillment
centers and our stores
to provide the same
experience that we
are providing to our
customers for the 1P products.
So they can use our fulfillment
centers to store products
and use our logistics network to
delivery and same-day delivery
or--
actually we have 35%
of our deliveries
in Brazil in the last 48 hours.
And we want to provide the same
thing for these merchants that
are using our platform.
That's it.
So back to Kiran.
[APPLAUSE]
KIRAN DAVULURI: Thanks Fatala.
That was pretty amazing
to hear about your journey
and your plans.
All right.
So one of the things that--
first of all, thank
you, Jimit and Fatala,
for sharing your
stories with us.
It's amazing to see
how the different paths
and the different
ways that retailers
can use to move their existing
applications onto the Cloud.
And essentially,
all we are looking
for is to make sure that
the customers can get what
they want when they want it.
And that is essentially the
goal of all of the retailers
that are there today.
And thank you for
sharing your stories.
And I would like you all to give
a warm applause to both Jimit
and Andre because what
they've done is amazing.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
So for the audience,
what I'd like to do
is based on what
you've seen today,
do you feel that you are
ready for a peak season?
And if it's not yes, I'd
love to chat with you
and talk about how we can make
whatever your concerns are
go away and get
you to [INAUDIBLE]..
And I'd love to
work with you all.
So what are the next steps?
So there are multiple
steps that you can take.
First thing is if you have
a Google account team,
please reach out to
them, talk to them.
And they can help you guide
through the journey that
is required, bring
all the resources that
are necessary for you
guys to be successful.
We have a brand
new retail website.
So if you can go
g.co/cloud/retail
that's our new
retail landing page.
And it has tons
of great content,
not just around e-commerce
but around all of the value
that we can bring to
retailers on Google Cloud.
And lastly, feel
free to email me.
My email is over there.
I'd love to have
conversations with you
and help you out
in any way we can
and point you to the right
resources if that is required.
We look forward to
working with you.
Since we do have
a five minute, I
would like to invite
Jimit and Andre on stage.
If there are any questions,
we can take some questions.
If not, thank you so
much for your time.
Have a great last day at Next.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]